taijuan goes to the polls on Saturday
with the islands leader sighing when
hoping for a second term in office but
her campaign suffered a setback when her
campaign spokeswoman resigned after
making controversial statements in an
interview to Deutsche Welle in an
interview with a Chinese service link
Jing Yi said supporting unification with
China would amount to treason Lin later
said her choice of words had been
imprecise now for reference sake China
and its influence in Taiwan is a major
subject in Taiwan politics given its
size and the fact that China claims
Taiwan as a part of its territory any
comment to do with Taiwan's relations
with China are closely watched here's
more of what Lin Qing Yi said in an
interview with Deutsche Welle
first by definition is unification with
China treason
according to Taiwan's Constitution or at
least we agree that the Chinese
Communist Party has always been a
threatening party a threatening regime
to us China has missiles aimed at us and
keeps threatening to invade Taiwan by
force then from the perspective of a
state this kind of advocacy is treason
which is impermissible how far can we
allow the boundaries for free speech to
go what you said may sound unacceptable
for pro unification supporters China is
a threat to our sovereignty but what
they mean is that we should abandon
Taiwan sovereignty in order to unite
with China is that treason in many cases
that's why we amended the National
Security law last year it's unacceptable
for Taiwan's retired generals to attend
lectures in China and political
activities or military parades their
pension should be stripped in this case
because it hugely jeopardizes national
sovereignty particularly towards
national defense and politics for more
we can go across to DW correspondent
Phoebe Kong in our East Asia Bureau in
Taipei Phoebe now this isn't the first
time treason in relation to contact with
China has been discussed in Taiwan why
are Lin Qing Yi's comments causing such
a storm what reason is a criminal act
and that high ones
national security laws right now
but when somebody tries to collude with
foreign forces to do something to
undermine Taiwan's national sovereignty
they may be convicted
but during database interview or
lynching he claims that even if someone
supports or advocates
unification with China will constitute
treason so on spots and I'm stirred
controversy and in within the island and
cause backfire to presidents because
people criticize that they doubt if this
is a kind of infringement of freedom of
speech that the government is trying to
convict someone simply based on the
speech solely but not the actual
behavior and so this is the reason why
this core system in Taiwan and this
comes particularly sensitive at the
moment when Taiwanese Parliament just
enacted and new infiltration or anti
infiltration law that prevents China
from meddling into Taiwan's election and
politics so some skeptics they worry
that this may indicate a harder line
taken by the ruling party that they may
limit the scoop of free speech or when
they talk something about like
unification with China in the future
just speaking about the election which
is just days away Taiwan's leader
sighing when herself has accused China
of interfering in the election how
concerned are people about this well
people are very concerned about the
alleged interference from China that
particularly the misinformation campaign
which is suspected to be carried out by
China like on the island and when we
look at the last local election on
Taiwan reports I found that quite a
number of Chinese social media accounts
spread misinformation and affect news on
the rifles and on the other hand
supports Beijing friendly candidates so
on people are worried that Beijing is
using this kind of mat acting to
manipulate voters opinion and citizens
have set up faction groups to counter
rumors online and to clarify flat facts
to ordinary citizens
the authority also prosecute some people
over disseminating misinformation
Phoebe Kong in Taipei thank you very
much for speaking to us